schooling at home is widening attainment
gaps between rich and poor under
lockdown the ability to learn can be
stifled by environment and access to
technology year 12 students sharing
worries she's fallen behind as for a
while she struggled to get hold of a
laptop the government and schools expect
us to like maintain the expectations
they have grade wise and some of us
being at a disadvantage can't
necessarily produce that expectation
one student is so frustrated he wrote to
Sky News to complain that the government
isn't doing enough to as he put it
mitigate the months of lost learning
Erin Billingsley a year ten from Sutton
Coldfield is worried about the damage to
next year's GCSEs when we go back to
school everyone will be at different
stages of their courses and we'll have
mock exams start in year 11 and we will
only have half of the syllabus Erin
attends Fairfax Academy which says it
offers students five lessons a day and
keeps in touch through online surveys
phone calls and video but Erin's fellow
pupil Lily says the government should
ensure that schools can have digital
face-to-face contact they could
definitely get scores like encourage
scores to put us on zoom' cause more and
utilize all of these things that we
could be using what we would normally be
spending in lesson and getting support
from the teachers we are spending on our
own and when we do need that help you
can message the teachers as most of them
do reply but some of them don't serve a
company teach a tap found hundreds of
thousands of students mostly from
disadvantaged backgrounds are studying
for less than an hour a day since
schools closed in deprived areas 43
percent of secondary school teachers
said their pupils studied for less than
an hour which compares to just four
percent in private schools and 14
percent in affluent intake state schools
where students work for much longer at
home this work ethic gap is widening as
the lockdown continues and teach tap
says the government should set minimum
standards of Education in this period
taking how schools get cleaned but not
what type sort of learning goes on is
very unusual and is disappointing the
government has promised two hundred
thousand laptops for disadvantaged
children they've not made sure that
those in the hands of those pupils so I
think that's one reason why the
government aren't saying that schools
have to deliver online learning because
they know that they haven't made sure
that every people has got the ability to
do it I think that this coronavirus
exposes a deep digital divide in our
country the digital haves and the
digital have-nots but we must have
summer schools we must offer these left
behind pupils a chance to catch up while
some year tens in the state sector
believed they were falling behind those
in fee-paying schools are more confident
samuel from san edwards senior school
has a full time table of online streamed
lessons they were teachers cameras on so
it's good to see because it makes you
feel like you're properly in school
blake so although it's different like
getting into that mindset afternoon
oakley oliver patrick or you're all
coming in nine you're all flooding in
the headmaster at some edwards primary
even streams an assembly to his students
every day but many children elsewhere
feel they're on their own while much
focus to speed on when schools will
reopen there's not as much on the
varying impact lockdown is having on the
nation's pupils and children like Aaron
want that to change
Jason Farrell Sky News